io
wow
i ragazzi sembra una scelta di rob lowe
quelle paurose venuti suoi dottori
guardate dove siamo
lo vedete quel castello laggiù
bellissimo stiamo d'irlanda e oggi
faremo una sala in città difende cioè
dovremmo mangiare comprare cose solo del
colore dei nostri occhi
chi vincerà secondo voi lo deciderete
voi alla fine del video chi vince e c'è
chi ha comprato mangiato cose più belle
rispetto all'altro ovviamente vitale è
felicissimo al lancio dove si mangia io
sono sempre pronto non vedo l'ora
andiamo devo mangiare
marroni e bell importate che mangiamo ci
interessa noi reagiamo sì sì telefono
mangiare cose marroni bene i tuoi occhi
marroni sì è vero sono marroni ma sono
anche non son e ridono gialli non
utilizzando il meno io invece posso
mangiare in realtà io ho un po di colori
negli occhi possono mangiare cose verdi
celesti e gialle
come gialle dove c'è un po di giallo
negli occhi guardate ero io non ci credo
guardate lo vedete tre colori differenti
e io sono uno dei tanti colori e anch'io
tutti colori marrone l'arancione
non è vero non si vedere sul marrone né
arancione come noi siamo nella strada
principale ovviamente siamo felicissimi
di aver patito lo è io non ci vedo
niente perché ho gli occhi anche se ho
gli occhi di tre colori i miei occhi
sono super e iper sensibili quindi devo
per forza mettere gli occhiali di meno
la luce è il vento mi fa lacrimare
presenta
allora ciò appena fermato una fan che
non so come ci ha riconosciuto subito se
stai guardando questo video chat per
karina grazie per averci salutato siamo
abbracciate i miei occhi hanno iniziato
a lacrimare ancora di più tenero a casa
piangendo
mi succedono sempre queste cose quando
vinco troppi infatti se mi avete
incontrato vi ricorderete che io
probabilmente stavo lacrimando come
sempre comunque siamo super contenti di
cioccolati svelando scriveteci nei
commenti se voi ci siete mai stati
scriveteci nei commenti ai ragazzi da me
è for chi guarda da qui sulla mia spalla
vuole stare qui tra l'altro con vitale
dicevamo guardate somiglia a vitale
guardate la faccia su miglia apicale
guardate
sembri spiaccicato da un carro tutti
forti non farti un po così allora oggi
prima di andare ad isolando dobbiamo
andare a comprare delle scarpe comode
perché io pensavo
ok queste mie scarpe andranno bene
guardate le mie scarpe sono delle
converse con platform e per me sono
comodissimi quindi ho detto sì dài
andranno benissimo ieri abbiamo
camminato tutto il giorno dalla mattina
fino alla sera e i piedi mi facevano
malissimo quindi consiglio se le
iniziative la portata delle scarpe super
super comode e poi devo anche prendere
degli occhiali da sole perché io
ovviamente li ho dimenticati a casa e il
cielo qua parigi è stranissimo
soprattutto se avete gli occhi chiari fa
malissimo agli occhi guardate guardate
come il cielo e
bianco bianco grigio non lo so e sì è
vero anche se io gli occhi chiusi
formale anche a me questo voto che l'ha
anche se io agli occhi marroni
quest'anno
guarda che bello qua dalla finestra
dell'hotel si vede la prima di giardino
labirinto è bellissimo ma magari di
porto lì perché così se ti perdi il
resto tempo possa dare a mangiare tutto
quello che voglio restare a te mi hai
rubato un po chi dice
sai perchè perchè lui una forchetta
quindi mi può aiutare a mangiare i
migliori amici
perché il mio amico mio amico fidato per
mangiare ok mi sono riappropriata di
fork i falchi non scappare più ad
abitare sono ti costringerà a tali da
mangiare per tutto ciò comunque se vi
state chiedendo ma come fa orchi a fare
l'isola tua spalla alla fine del video
vi svelerò il segreto di come fa a stare
qua in equilibrio quindi verrà del video
fino alla fine è lasciato un mi piace mi
raccomando pronti tutti tornati ho
cambiato le scarpette
che stupida ginnastica è tutto perché
non esco mai con la tuta ma l'importante
è essere comodi soprattutto quando si
deve camminare cose di tanto tu
professor di sdram siete pronti andiamo
subito a dire comunque lo re giusto i
tuoi occhi sono solo celesti e tu non
devi mangiare solo così presto io invece
posso mangiare tutto quello che voglio
martina
allora sono anche un po vertighe
disonesta e verde
no niente gialloreto gialla non ci credo
che c'è il giallo vita ne è geloso
perché io a tre colori
possono più cosa invece che lui no ma ti
giuro che c'è un po di giallo
credo dimostri ora ho un idea ok
sentiamo questa idea allora siccome è
vitale non ci crede che io ho tanti
colori negli occhi faremo questa foto
bellissima in pratica chi fotografano
l'occhio e lo ingrandiscono e vedono
tutti come richiede l'occhio guardate
uscirà proprio così e lo farà anche
vitale così vediamo se anche lui ha
qualche colore nascosto magari i suoi
occhi non sono solo marroni è così
infatti per speriamo di sì così magari
esce fuori qualche colore in più posso
mangiare tante altre cose guardateli e
ci sono i prezzi quindi magari posso
anche prendere un prezzo al dopo è
ok non loro vado
si no
i ragazzi dopo tipo un'ora di attesa
finalmente le stampe dei nostri occhi
vediamo come sono allora vedo l'ora
questo è l'occhio di vitale guardate non
mi aspettavo sembrava che per chi
fossero solo neri invece guardate quanti
colori si sono aspetto qui c'è la
ragione c'è il nero c'è anche il giallo
il gianna chissà quante altre cose
brutte cose non mi aspettavo così tanto
giallo anch'io ho preso per mollare
moltissimo non me le aspettavo di avere
tutti questi colori
arancione che mi ero il tuo occhio frego
e marrone o nero
tutti mi chiedono di che colore ha gli
occhi ma io non so mai rispondere bene
perché non sono proprio essere questo
non sono neanche blu non sono neanche
verdi sono un po mix di colori vediamo
dobbiamo scoprire insieme
ma quanti colori ci sono anche nei tuoi
occhi
belli sono tante macchiette gialle anche
nel mio o ci sono siti ci sono dei
riflessi gialli quindi c'è un po di blu
un pò di
bertoli aspetta dove sta il verdolino
vedo nessun bertolino verde acqua
non lo so non è vero non c'è nessun
verdolino sia un po di verdolino è un po
di giallo ma questo è giallo arancione
non si capisce perché in queste macchie
strade arancioni wow da quest'estate
abbiamo capito che gli occhi possono
avere un sacco di simone sono tutti
bellissimi sia quelli chiari che quelli
scuri ma ora
come dice vitale che stiamo per
attraversare il cappello della
principessa si contentano con tantissimo
vediamo cosa c'è dentro al castello
siete curiosi di vedere cosa c'è dentro
il castello entriamo adesso questo il
libro della bella addormentata
addormentata si scusa essere stata
tormentata hanno chiuso tutto sia
dormendo la svegliamo e certo se
guardate la casetta bianca
la doccia fredda attiva
si sta cucinando qualcosa
la mela avvelenata no effetti ce l'ha in
mano d'italia sempre stato il maggiore
ben pure la mela della strega venerata
ok ragazzi stiamo per entrare nella casa
stregata infestata di fantasmi sapete
che io adoro le cose paurose ma
sicuramente le adorate anche voi se mi
seguite se siete iscritti al mio canale
e volevo farvi vedere una cosa allora
guardate la casa infestata stava
passando il trenino della che dopo
faremo se troverò il coraggio di fare
quella montagna russa lasciate un mi
piace se volete che faccia quella
montagna russa date la casa stregata e
ditemi cosa vi ricorda non sembra la
casa stregata della copertina del mio
libro
solo che un po più colorata a proposito
se non avete ancora storie paurose a
scuola di misteri non potete non averlo
cliccate il link e descrizione per
prenderlo subito vi piacerà tantissimo e
ora pronti andiamo nella casa infestata
di fantasmi dovete sapere una cosa io ho
paura delle montagne russe e delle
altezze ma non ho paura delle cause dei
fantasmi e delle calze paurosi invece
vitale non ha paura delle montagne russe
ma ha paura delle case intestate e si è
vero pure dalle case infestate dai
fantasmi e dei mostri a preferisco fare
le montagne russe mesi
rassegna tutta velocità sulla casa
infestata
allora faremo la casa intestata e
vedrete vitale che ha paura no non le
multe di rose facciamo dopodomani
andiamo alla carta intestata
si ci sposta non è che ci schiacciano
ragazzi sembra uno chef room di rob lowe
quelle paurose e bellissimo adoro questo
vado
[Musica]
mai negli anni poggio differenza da un
soffio
[Applauso]
mamma mia che la stanza era troppo buia
adoro troppo questa casa intestata
voglio trasferirmi qua va bene sì sì
vieni pure io ero io rimango dall'altra
volta è bellissimo guardate che
bellissimo
pauroso
ci sono i quadri che cambiano la fa
appunto la cura
guardate questo lampadario
casello troppo che vedremo i fantasmi
non vedono ora no io non vedo l'ora no
no io vedo vedo l'ora adesso anzi io
[Musica]
amiamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
top ten
ricci ha detto rai
ciao
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
credo proprio di si sono aperti
abbiamo pregato
molto belli 90 paura secondo me
per me non ha fatto per niente paura
paura le montagne russe come quello che
volevo togliere un strada zona
ciao ragazze allora siamo passati dalla
dure che ha il macaron francesi guardate
un po i colori
la
celeste e lo proviamo subito sembra
buonissimo iniziamo vediamo come questo
com'è buono ma non capisco che sapore
alte a chi dovrebbe essere al tempo al
tuffo altezza sembra
lampone forte come lo zero che ve lo
dico tu non puoi però per dilatare la
formula sociale
è piaciuto valori e del capitale che si
può mangiare solo quello marrone no
questo è mio
queste merde mio allora questo è marrone
da quelle giallo il mio
dovrebbe essere caramello e burrosa al
carro non eravamo al burro sballo
e vitale voleva mangiarsi tutto il
negozio voleva mangiarselo tutto è buono
ne posso prendere altri 8 ha accusato un
imprenditore parato cammello prossimo
avuto perché sapete che ciò altri colori
negli occhi giallo vediamo che questo è
farà limone
secondo me non è limone fa questo
giappone no no no così lo stato io
proviamo quest'altro poi scegliamo il
vincitore
queste verde
pistacchio vince il pistacchio buoni
come faccio a dirlo chi vince se non la
saggia dire
stiamo per giocare a sparare quella
[Applauso]
siamo per giocare al gioco in cui
speriamo che torni toy story toy story è
uno dei mesi sono presenti disney pixar
l'avete visto
e poi vedremo chi fa più punti e secondo
voi chi vincerà i giorni tale
[Musica]
casagiove
ma sembra che fare rob lowe dovranno
essere inclusa nella vita reale
pensi che cos'è quell'uomo
ho fatto
[Musica]
panico
guarda di quasi
[Applauso]
ma ci proverò
ci siamo bloccati qui non lo so che cosa
è successo forse colpa di vitale che se
un attacco liero
vitale e barato come in raw blog se no
non è vero io non ballo
quando parlo ovviamente si spera gelato
come questi sono giocato qui in rivolta
ecco tu hai fatto un sacco di fusi ho
superato mutare eppure sto sparando a
caso non penso che gli occhiali per
vederci meglio ma non bastano
credo che si è bloccato dopo
è bellissima questo gioco
si no
no
[Musica]
e visto che abbiamo verde e marrone
verde l'avvocato marrone il padre quindi
vitale maggiora il pane senza niente
ebbene oggi che già allora
anche
noi per nero
a me non mangia niente allora cosa bene
la pole meno
marrone onion rings tutti
noi assaggio vediamo come sono questi
anelli di cipolla si si passeggiamo
sono croccanti sono anche caldissimi a
sandra
a momenti
su momenti era quella la tua ti ha
mangiato un anello di cipolla non ti
permettere mentre io queste amene uno no
è stato un errore noi ma tutti e due non
sarà un altro cioccolato non te lo puoi
mangiare tutti e due
perché
il cibo mangiato italia più vincerlo ma
non è così hai ragione che ci con
marrone manzoni pall
allora prendiamo un vano cioccola va
bene solo uno si sia solo uno solo uno e
anch'io prendo fanno cioccolato funzione
vitale
segrate questo no no no è troppo grande
no
il grande più di una mano
ciao ragazzi continua all'astral è già
abbiamo appena preso un bubble t
sapete che cos'è il bubble ti è un tè
se non sbaglio giapponese comunque
olistico che anche delle perline delle
palline di tapioca che si mangiano
la cannuccia e così grande perché quando
vai poi a bere il tè devi anche se bevi
manchi anche le palline erano buoni
quindi sia baby che mangi intatti vitale
felicissimo il colore è un mix tra
verde e marrone quindi un po il mio un
popolo di evitare questo possiamo per la
pittura arte per me marrone con frate
come la per la ditta pilota in gommosa
a messaggiare dovuta non tutto in
tremila
buono perché ma è molto bello poter
meglio e mangiare lo stesso tempo che mi
piace molto lo dico sempre io
mangerebbero
voi avete mai bevuto il babbo di queste
sono le palline che rimangono sotto
scriveteci nei commenti se l'avete mai
bevuto allora questo per il colore dei
miei occhi quindi colore di vino io ho
preso qualcosa che marrone o topolino al
torino che sarà ridotto sciolto questo
crea questo pur di finire a portare
felicissimo
vediamo approviamo un buon cioccolato
molto vitale ad ora il cioccolato
neanche la bonilla vabbè quale qualsiasi
tipo ancora vitale soprattutto i dolci
fritti
lo finirà in 4 secondi
proviamo
e aspetta un momento è diventato un
bianco non è più marrone non lo puoi
mangiare
ma nell'occhio c'è anche il bianco
pensato tanto il bianco bianco
dell'occhio è vero ciao ragazzi siamo
sul trenino siamo in prima fila
meno male non sappiamo
dove sta al volante il volante per
guidare il treno
parte acceleratore
[Musica]
[Applauso]
e perché
[Musica]
questo
si no
che bello
non c'è pace tra gli sportivi
[Musica]
affinità benzina
ho già finito almeno questo non faceva
troppa paura e andava piano è stato un
momento dove ci siamo osservati
non possiamo scendere da farsi
[Musica]
flash forward avanti nel tempo perché ci
siamo dimenticati di farvi vedere cosa
abbiamo comprato per la sala perché la
sala leggera puoi mangiare compra
ristoro corde del colore di toyota il
mio caro for kids che vita e vuole
rubare per mangiare se aveva state lette
comprato questa talpa tbc mouse supercar
in a cell sé stessi ma per chi approva
ha detto sì va bene l'ha fatta bisogna
allora che il ghiaccio si questa felpa
gialla di stizza
bambini borsetta verde acqua e mi
aspettavo questo non è verde si perde
acqua il verde
degli habitat e che verde acqua
e poi ultima cosa questa cosa
stranissima è una maschera
c'è una maschera una sorta di maschera
che fa la luce led non maschera luminosa
se guardate le regole cura guardate si
vede il colore blu forse c'è troppa luce
non si vede
anche se vuoi andare a tenere verbo
questo
dramma si può anche cambiare colore
guardate
questo colore arancione e rosa ma per la
challenge blu
come lo presti con due battaglie l'erba
da tagliare l'erba a proposito vi avevo
detto che avremmo svelato come farà
porti a stare qua è la spalla c'è un
trucchetto diete pronti a scoprire il
segreto di porti qua sotto forti che c'è
scritto lasciami mangiare in pace non
capisco cosa c'è scritto comunque c'è
una calamita a cui si attacca la
calamità si mette qua sotto la maglietta
e porti rimane attaccato
[Musica]
ma il tom ford che ha detto che rimanete
a casa non ti abbatti e ora vediamo cosa
ha comprato vitale di marrone ha
comprato solo una cosa poi allora io di
marra
allora io di barolo ho trovato solo
questa la gravità di forti
sì ho preso un altra cosa però voglio
posizionare forti e qui su dimenticato
forchetta la forchetta e in mangione
come dici sì sito poniamo mangiare certo
allora io ho trovato solo una cosa di
marrone che questa
supercar e non vedo l'ora di provarla ma
se come distante devo aprirla vero prima
spesso fuori chi aspettava
dire che si sta benissimo come vista
forti
e ora vi lasciamo allo spettacolo finale
di diesel end con i fuochi d'artificio
renault di pinocchio
[Musica]
felicissimo
prendila caravello si può
più nascondere
[Musica]
dov'è pinocchio c'è
ecco altri scopi
[Musica]
ecco finocchio
la casa di finocchio
a
[Musica]